Найбільше громадяни ФРН подорожують саме Німеччиною.
Вражає. Адже практично кожен німець може собі дозволити відпочинок за кордоном.
Утім, із 70 мільйонів подорожей, які німці здійснили минулоріч,
27% припадає на Німеччину.
Це найбільший показник.
Улюблений іспанський острів Майорка
на почесному другому місці із 13-ма відсотками.
Що це - туристичний патріотизм?
Можливо, але передусім по-німецьки детальна та по-хлопськи проста
організація туристичних маршрутів у будь-якому куточку країни.
У Німеччині є все для відпочинку. І море -
аж два - на півночі країни. І Альпи - на південному сході.
Великі мегаполіси і затишні німецькі містечка з фахверковими будиночками.
Національні парки, заповідники та дива природи.
Свої "діснейленди" для відпочинку з дітьми.
На автівці, поїздом, велосипедом чи пішки -
сі маршрути в деталях можна знайти в інтернеті.
І дороги до будь-якої туристичної принади - відмінні.
Знайти туристичний маршрут на будь-який смак надзвичайно просто.
Кожне німецьке місто має сторінку в інтернеті.
Просто задаєте назву міста, наприклад, Берлін, крапка, де-е.
На кожній такій сторінці є обов'язково розділ туризм.
У ньому - найрізноманітніші пропозиції
із детальним описом маршрутів, годин роботи,
вартості квитків та телефонами туроператорів.
Наприклад, на сайті Берліна пропонують двогодинну екскурсію на Тойфельсберг,
або "Чортову гору". Її можна замовити щодня
з 10 до 14 за 39 євро з людини.
Утім, до цього унікального місця можна прийти і без екскурсії.
Колись тут була американська станція прослуховування,
що ловила сигнал зі Східної Німеччини.
Нині - це одна з найбільших галерей стріт-арту в Європі
та улюблене місце креативної молоді.
За цим принципом можна вибрати туристичну ціль у будь-якому куточку Німеччини
та отримати повний пакет інформації.
До речі, у Німеччині є 44 пам'ятки культурної спадщини ЮНЕСКО:
такі як Аахенський чи Кельнський собори.
Усі пам'ятки описані на сайті організації
і до них легко дістатися залізницею.
Німецька залізниця заохочує подорожувати
в межах федеральних земель та на вихідних.
Наприклад, по землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія
можна цілий день їздити регіональними поїздами
та автобусами з одним квитком.
На одну людину він коштуватиме 31 євро, а на п'ятьох - 46.
За цим же принципом діє квиток вихідного дня -
тільки ним можна пересуватися на регіональних поїздах усією Німеччиною.
На п'ятьох він коштуватиме 68 євро.
На сайті залізниці достатньо ввести пункт відправлення, наприклад, Бонн,
та пункт призначення - скажімо, Аахен.
Обираєте дату, час відправлення і ось він - план поїздки
з усіма пересадками.
Німецькі потяги пересуваються зі швидкістю
від 200 до 300 кілометрів на годину.
Тож за день легко дістатися в будь-який куточок Німеччини.
Один з найдовших маршрутів німецької залізниці -
1225 кілометрів від північного Кіля на узбережжі Балтійського моря
до східного Пассау на кордоні з Австрією.
Цю відстань можна подолати поїздом за 12 годин.
Чим раніше бронюєш поїздку, тим дешевші квитки на потяг.
У поїзд можна брати і велосипеди.
Утім, для любителів покрутити педалі по цілій країні прокладені веломаршрути.
А таких велолюбителів чимало. Більше половини німців
регулярно користується велосипедами.
Один з найпопулярніших маршрутів пролягає над річкою Ельба.
Його протяжність - 860 кілометрів.
Вказівники дозволяють спланувати подорож і не збитися з  маршруту.
Так само детально позначені усі піші маршрути для любителів походів.
Навіть лісові стежки пронумеровані,
очищені та оснащені вказівниками.
Детальні маршрути і карти для походів можна знайти в інтернеті
або придбати путівники в книгарнях.
Їх дуже багато для усіх регіонів, адже походи -
на шостому місці серед улюблених видів відпочинку німців.
За опитуваннями, 10% німців
часто віддають перевагу такому активному відпочинку.
Одним із найулюбленіших видів відпочинку німців є кемпінг.
Лише у першій половині 2018 рок
в Німеччині на дороги виїхали 46 тисяч нових будиночків на колесах.
У Німеччині працює майже три тисячі місць для кемпінгу,
найбільше - у Баварії.
Просто зупинитися деінде зі своїм будинком на колесах не можна.
Дозволено лише в спеціально призначених кемпінгових місцях
за окрему плату.
Вартість коливається залежно від послуг кемпінгу.
Туалет чи душ - це само собою.
Та за бажання можна вибрати місце з басейном,
безпосередньо на березі моря чи озера, із дитячим майданчиком чи рестораном.
Головна принада кемпінгу - свобода пересування
та відпочинок на природі, до якого дедалі більше тяжіють німці.